It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
OK, the first thing you need to know is that the nuns came to Todd. Todd did not go to the nuns. His wife worked with these nuns at a Catholic charity.
好的，你需要知道的第一件事是修女找上了托德，而不是托德去找修女。他的妻子曾在这些修女开办的慈善机构工作。
The Todd in the story actually is Todd Bachmann, who works on our radio show. He's our production manager, which means that he sees the bills get paid and that the equipment works and everything runs smoothly.
故事里的托德其实是托德·巴赫曼，他在我们的广播节目组工作。他是我们的制作经理，这意味着他负责处理账单、确保设备正常运转以及一切事务顺利进行。
Anyway, a couple years ago, these nuns that his wife worked with asked him to help out with this big black-tie charity event that they were throwing, this annual event. Donors pay a lot of money. There's a meal in a big hotel ballroom. And at some point during this thing, there's a presentation on stage about what the charity does. That's the part that the nuns wanted Todd to work on. One of the nuns actually asked him to direct this part of it.
总之，几年前，他妻子共事的这些修女请他帮忙筹备一场盛大的慈善晚宴，这是她们的年度活动。捐赠者会支付大笔费用。活动在大型酒店的宴会厅举行，包含用餐环节。在活动的某个阶段，舞台上会有关于慈善机构工作的演示。这就是修女们想让托德负责的部分。其中一位修女甚至请他执导这部分内容。
And I remember I just had all these delusions of grandeur. I was so passionate about it and so ready. And I just had it in my mind where these people in their tuxedos, they're at this event, and maybe there'd be some activity like chinking of the silverware and some hushed, mild conversation that's like almost whispering. And then my work turns on, and then pow! Silence. People actually listen. And they're moved. Like, yeah, this is totally what I can do.
我还记得当时自己充满了各种宏伟的幻想。我对此充满激情，也做好了充分准备。我的脑海里勾勒出这样的画面：穿着燕尾服的人们参加活动，背景里可能有刀叉碰撞的声音，还有近乎耳语般的低沉交谈。然后我的作品开始播放，接着——砰！全场寂静。人们真的在听，而且被打动了。我想，没错，这完全是我能做到的。
In previous years of this event, for the presentation part of it the nuns had some of the people who the charity had helped-- elderly people and young mothers-- come up onto the stage and read these little essays. And apparently, it felt a lot like school. You know, they got real nervous. It just felt like class somehow.
在往年的活动中，在演示环节，修女们会让慈善机构帮助过的一些人——老年人和年轻妈妈们——走上台阅读一些小短文。显然，这感觉很像学校。你知道的，他们会变得非常紧张。这感觉就像是在上课一样。
And Todd thought that he could do better. He had a vision. He had a vision, I'm telling you. He had just started working at our radio show at the time, and he thought, OK, you know he could do? He could interview these people on tape and then choose a couple of really, really great moments and play those to the crowd. And then people would come on up and take a bow or something. And on the tape, they would sound all relaxed and natural, and it would totally get to people.
托德认为他能做得更好。他有一个愿景。我敢说，他真的有一个愿景。当时他刚开始在我们的广播节目组工作，他想，好吧，你知道他能做什么吗？他可以把这些人的话录下来，然后挑选出几个非常棒的片段播放给观众听。之后人们再走上台鞠个躬之类的。录音里的他们听起来会非常放松自然，这绝对能打动人。
Maybe they'd even make more money out of it this way. And the sister in charge of the whole thing agreed with all of his ideas. But as the event got nearer, something strange slowly became clear.
也许这样还能筹到更多的钱。负责整个活动的修女同意了他所有的想法。但随着活动临近，一件奇怪的事情慢慢变得清晰起来。
She kept on really overemphasizing, "well, you're the director. So whatever you say, you're the director."
她一直在反复强调：“嗯，你是导演。所以无论你说什么，你都是导演。”
And what was funny about it is she never told me. It was so deft of her because she never clearly said, "no, no, no-- we're never going to do your idea." It was kind of like always hinted, like, "yeah, yeah, yeah-- we'll get to it. We'll get to it."
有趣的是，她从未真正那样告诉我。她很高明，因为她从没有明确地说：“不，不，不——我们绝不会采纳你的想法。”她总是暗示，比如：“是啊，是啊，是啊——我们会做到的，我们会做到的。”
But they never did get to it. And finally, after weeks and weeks of meetings, at the rehearsal, Todd's responsibility at the event were finally made clear to him, and they were not at all what he expected.
但他们从未真正去做。最后，在经历了数周的会议后，在彩排时，托德在活动中的职责终于对他明朗了，而这与他预想的完全不同。
It came down to there was a CD player, and she wanted me to just hit play on this CD song, which was 'Thank You," by Natalie Merchant.
最终的结果是，有一个CD播放器，她想让我做的仅仅是按下CD播放键，播放娜塔莉·莫森特的歌曲《感谢你》。
You got played by a nun.
你被修女耍了。
I got played by a nun. Here I thought that she actually wanted my input, and I remember being really frustrated and conflicted because I was really mad at this nun. And I just felt really guilty for being mad at this nun. And so I just felt really petty.
我被修女耍了。我还以为她真的想要我的投入，我记得当时感到非常沮丧和矛盾，因为我真的很生这位修女的气。但因为对修女感到生气，我又觉得非常内疚。所以我感觉自己真的很小家子气。
I just think that if you can be used by a nun, man, you can be used by anybody.
我只是觉得，如果一个人能被修女利用，伙计，那你会被任何人利用。
Yeah, exactly. I was coddled, like massaged, like, director, director.
没错，完全正确。我被娇惯了，就像被按摩一样，一口一个导演，导演地叫着。
[MUSIC - "THANK YOU" BY NATALIE MERCHANT]
[音乐 - 娜塔莉·莫森特的《感谢你》]
There's a whole of experiences like this. You're asked to do something, you think it's go one way, it turns out to be something completely different, and then you're stuck. You can't do anything about it. It's too late to quit. It's too late to get out of it. This can happen to you at work. It can happen to you with friends. It can happen on a plane. It can happen on a train. It could happen on a run. It can be caused by a nun.
生活中有很多这样的经历。你被要求做某事，你以为它会朝一个方向发展，结果却完全是另一回事，然后你就被困住了。你对此无能为力。退出已经太晚了，摆脱它也太晚了。这可能发生在你的工作中。可能发生在朋友之间。可能发生在飞机上。可能发生在火车上。可能发生在跑步时。它甚至可能由一位修女造成。
Today on our program we hear two rather dramatic examples of this phenomenon. Our program today, Not What I Signed Up For. Act One of our program, The Double Whammy, a story of someone who gets into two situations where things work out very differently than she thought they would. One of those situations with the president of the United States. Act Two, Small Fish, Smaller Pond. We have a story by Nick Hornby. Stay with us, and we will thank you.
今天我们的节目将听到两个关于这种现象的戏剧性例子。我们今天的节目主题是《非我所愿》。节目的第一幕《双重打击》，讲述了一个人陷入了两种局面，情况的发展与她所想的完全不同。其中一种情况涉及美国总统。第二幕《小鱼，小池塘》，我们有尼克·霍恩比的故事。请留在我们身边，我们会感谢你们。
[MUSIC - "THANK YOU" BY NATALIE MERCHANT]
[音乐 - 娜塔莉·莫森特的《感谢你》]
Act One. This story is one of those stories that starts off as a tragedy and ends up not exactly as a comedy, but it's one of those things where it just sort of sits there, you know, halfway between tragedy and comedy. It starts sad.
第一幕。这个故事属于那种以悲剧开头，结尾却算不上喜剧的故事，它就像是悬在那里，你知道的，介于悲剧和喜剧之间。开头很悲伤。
Marian Fontana. Her husband was a firefighter. He dies at the World Trade Center. And then after 9/11, she finds herself embroiled in a series of political fights with the city. The first one is to see that her husband's firehouse isn't shut down by the city. And then it goes on to how the cleanup is going on at the ground zero site. And in the course of this she starts an organization with some of the firefighters' widows.
玛丽安·丰塔纳。她的丈夫是一名消防员。他在世贸中心袭击中遇难。9/11事件后，她发现自己陷入了一系列与市政府的政治斗争中。首先是确保她丈夫所在的消防站不会被市政府关闭。然后是关于归零地清理工作进展的情况。在这个过程中，她与一些消防员遗孀一起成立了一个组织。
And she talks a lot to the press. She talked about these issues. She talked about the conditions that firefighters were working under when the World Trade Center attack happened. Her husband was earning less than $26,000 a year.
她经常接受媒体采访。她谈论了这些问题。她谈论了9/11袭击发生时消防员们所处的工作环境。她丈夫当时的年薪还不到26,000美元。
Anyway, so she's getting maybe 100 calls a day from all kinds of press. From Polish TV to Newark Radio. And she had to choose.
总之，她每天可能会接到100个来自各种媒体的电话。从波兰电视台到纽瓦克电台。她必须做出选择。
My criteria for doing media was that I needed to be able to talk about the organization and the site recovery. And that's really all I want to speak to. I didn't want to go on any tabloids or talk shows or anything like that.
我接受媒体采访的标准是，我需要能够谈论该组织和现场恢复工作。这真的是我想说的全部。我不想上任何小报或脱口秀之类的节目。
Did you find yourself in the situation, though, where in order to actually get out the message that you wanted to get out that you would be doing shows and would be giving interviews where a part of the interview would be, "well, tell us your sad story," and then another part would be, "OK, so now, what are you here to talk about?"
但是，你有没有发现自己陷入这样一种境地：为了真正传达你想要传达的信息，你不得不参加一些节目并接受采访，而采访的一部分会是“好吧，告诉我们你的悲伤故事”，然后另一部分是“好的，那么现在，你想谈些什么？”
Yes, yes. In fact, almost all of them do that. Because a lot of them were focused on the fact that my husband died on our anniversary. It was our eighth wedding anniversary, and they wanted to kind of give them a blow by blow of the day and how-- and I could understand that. I mean, it's human nature, I think, to want to know what happened. But I can understand why an interviewer would want to hear that, as well.
是的，是的。事实上，几乎所有的节目都这样。因为他们很多人都关注我丈夫死于我们结婚纪念日这一事实。那是我们第八个结婚纪念日，他们想让我详细描述那一天的经过，以及如何……我能理解这一点。我的意思是，想知道发生了什么事是人性使然。我也能理解为什么采访者会想听这些。
Another firefighter's wife, who was a PR person, helped her field the 100 press calls a day and figure out which interviews to do. Which leads us to this story, about a time when Marian ended up in a very different situation than she thought she was signing up for.
另一位曾做过公关的消防员妻子帮她处理每天100个媒体电话，并决定接受哪些采访。这引出了我们的这个故事，讲述了玛丽安最终陷入了一种与她预期完全不同的境地。
I was usually running on the cell phone from one place to the next, and that's when my PR person called and told me that there was a news show that I had never heard of called E-Online, and would I want to go on that and speak about the organization. And I said, "sure," not knowing what it was.
我通常拿着手机从一个地方赶到另一个地方，就在那时，我的公关人员打电话告诉我有一个叫E-Online的新闻节目，我以前从未听说过，问我想不想上那个节目谈谈我们的组织。我说：“当然可以”，但我并不知道那是什么。
And what did you understand about E-Online?
那么你对E-Online有什么了解吗？
At the time, I just figured it was some kind of web news thing that I didn't know about, not being very computer savvy, and that they'd get their little byte about what I do and that would be it. And whenever I did these news shows, there would be a tiny little green room and a tiny little makeup room. You know, the new shows are all five minute interviews. You're brought into sometimes the newsroom itself, and they sit you in a chair and you talk to a camera, you never talk to a person.
当时，我以为那只是某种我不知道的网络新闻，因为我不太懂电脑，我想他们只会剪辑一段关于我工作的简短片段，然后就结束了。每当我参加这些新闻节目时，通常都有一个小小的候播室和一个小小的化妆间。你知道的，新闻节目通常都是五分钟的采访。他们有时会把你带进新闻编辑室，让你坐在椅子上对着镜头说话，你永远不会对着真人说话。
So I was very startled to arrive outside of these studios where there were about 100 Puerto Rican girls in down coats and giant earrings kind of lined up to go into the Fox studios. And I figured, "oh, they're probably going to see Ricki Lake or something." And then got ushered into this back room, and there was a huge maze of doors, and we stopped at this door that had my name on it. And that was in itself kind of startling and not protocol for what I was used to.
所以当我到达这些演播室外，看到大约100个穿着羽绒服、戴着巨大耳环的波多黎各女孩排队准备进入福克斯演播室时，我非常吃惊。我想，“哦，她们大概是去看里基·莱克的节目之类的吧。”然后我被带进了一个后室，那里有很多迷宫般的门，我们在一个写着我名字的门前停了下来。这本身就让人吃惊，也不符合我习惯的礼节。
I opened the door and there was a fruit basket and a phone and makeup mirrors. And I went, "my, my, my-- what is this?" And they said, "make yourself comfortable. We'll come in and get you into makeup."
我打开门，里面有水果篮、电话和化妆镜。我说：“天哪，天哪，这是什么？”他们说：“请便。我们会进来帮你化妆。”
And I said, "OK." so I started making phone calls. I was supposed to be at an Eliot Spitzer meeting, and I was missing it.
我说：“好的。”于是我开始打电话。我本该去参加一个埃利奥特·斯皮策的会议，但我错过了。
Eliot Spitzer the attorney general?
埃利奥特·斯皮策，那位总检察长？
Right. We were dealing with the victim's comp issue at the time.
对。我们当时正在处理受害者赔偿问题。
And so next thing you know, I'm being ushered into the hallway. And I start to hear the audience, and they're going "whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo." Like the Arsenio Hall Show used to do. And then I really started to get worried. I said, "what is this?" I said, "what is going on?"
接下来，你知道的，我被带到了走廊。我开始听到观众的声音，他们在喊“呜，呜，呜，呜，呜，呜”。就像以前的《阿塞尼奥·霍尔秀》那样。我真的开始担心了。我说：“这是什么？”我说：“到底发生了什么？”
What is E-Online?
E-Online是什么？
Well, I misunderstood. It was the Iyanla show. They walked us from the back across the stage, and I saw these big giant letters spelling Iyanla. I Y A N L A. I quickly realized I was definitely in the wrong place, or completely misunderstood what the show was about.
嗯，我误会了。那是伊安拉的节目。他们从后台带着我们走过舞台，我看到了拼成伊安拉（Iyanla）的巨大字母。I Y A N L A。我很快意识到我绝对走错地方了，或者完全误解了这个节目的性质。
And so I leaned over to the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] woman next to me, and I said, "what is this?" And she said, "oh, it's Iyanla." She's like, "the late-night Oprah." And I said, "oh, oh, OK." And I'm trying to turn to the other woman on the other side of me and find out more when they ushered us to be quiet. And they did a countdown, and the cameras rolled. And out comes this very pretty African American woman with tightly cropped hair.
于是我凑向旁边的女士问道：“这是什么？”她说：“哦，这是伊安拉。”她说：“那是深夜版的奥普拉。”我说：“哦，哦，好吧。”我正试图转向另一边的女士打听更多情况时，他们示意我们保持安静。他们进行了倒计时，摄像机开始转动。走出来的是一位留着紧贴头皮的短发、非常漂亮的非裔美国女性。
How's everybody?
大家好吗？
[AS A GROUP] Good!
[异口同声] 好！
Good! I know you! Don't I look gorgeous? Tell the truth.
好！我认识你们！我不看起来很华丽吗？说实话。
She's like, "today's show is about people who've been to hell and back." And I said, "oh, OK. This is going to be interesting."
她说：“今天的节目是关于那些经历过地狱又回来的人。”我说：“哦，好吧。这会很有趣。”
And you know, this was in December. And they had just found my husband, actually, on December 6. And so I had just had a funeral for him, I had just had a burial. And you know, I was really not back from hell, clearly.
你知道，那是12月份。他们其实才在12月6日找到了我丈夫。所以我才刚为他办了葬礼，才刚把他下葬。你知道的，我显然还没从地狱里回来。
Today you're going to meet people who, when they were backed up against the wall, hmph! They learned something about themselves. And they've taken the scars and they've turn them into lessons, positive lessons.
今天你们将见到一些人，当他们被逼到墙角时，哼！他们学到了关于自己的东西。他们把伤疤变成了教训，积极的教训。
And so I was kind of sitting there, and they brought up the short, very fit guy first. And they showed this the video that he had made that looked like the lens had been smeared in Vaseline, you know. And it was this sad music, and they showed a close-up of a liquor glass. And they said, "Tim had a happy life until he fell into drugs and alcohol and was arrested for drunk driving." And you know, the sad music plays.
我当时就坐在那儿，他们先带上了那个身材矮小、非常健壮的家伙。他们播放了他制作的视频，看起来镜头上像是涂了凡士林，你知道的。背景是悲伤的音乐，他们给了酒杯一个特写。他们说：“蒂姆在陷入毒品和酒精并因酒驾被捕前过着幸福的生活。”你知道的，悲伤的音乐响着。
"But he turned himself around when he started to do triathlons, and then teach other kids the power of being physically active." And you know, everyone starts to be very moved. And the girls, the Puerto Rican girls behind me who were outside start crying, and they're all very touched by this video. And then the lights come up and Iyanla introduced him about his role coaching teenagers.
“但他开始练习铁人三项后改过自新，然后教其他孩子身体活动的力量。”你知道的，每个人都开始非常感动。我身后的那些波多黎各女孩开始哭泣，她们都被这段视频触动了。然后灯光亮起，伊安拉介绍了他在辅导青少年方面的角色。
I'm always so grateful that God is god of a second chance. Any moment can be the moment.
我总是非常感激上帝是给予第二次机会的上帝。任何时刻都可以是转机时刻。
She was using all these platitudes. I just remember her saying, "you know you hit rock bottom because God made the rock."
她一直在用那些陈词滥调。我只记得她说：“你知道你触底反弹了，因为上帝创造了岩石。”
And I knew this time, that was it.
在那一刻，我就知道，就是这样。
When it's time, it's time.
当时机成熟时，就是时机。
There was an insincerity there.
这里有一种虚伪。
I'm being inspired.
我感到深受鼓舞。
I used to sit and I'd think, "I want to do that someday. I think it's neat."
我以前常坐着想：“我希望有一天能做到那样。我觉得那很酷。”
Wow.
哇。
Did the thought occur to you, "I can just leave, I can walk out the door?"
你有想过“我可以离开，我可以走出去”吗？
Well, we were sitting in the front row, and there were a lot of cameras on stage. And I guess we were [? miked up. And I kind of felt trapped. I really didn't feel like I was in a position to leave. And I couldn't even talk. They kept silencing us and telling us, it's "quiet on the set."
嗯，我们坐在前排，舞台上有许多摄像机。我想我们被[麦克风]收音了。我感觉被困住了。我真的觉得我没有立场离开。我甚至不能说话。他们一直让我们安静，告诉我们要“现场安静”。
We're back, and we're talking to people who've been to hell and back.
我们回来了，我们正在和那些从地狱归来的人交谈。
Then we came back from commercial, and they brought up a very large woman with gray hair. And she also had a film. And she was from Boston, so she had this very thick Boston accent. She's like, "Mark was a shy and beautiful boy."
然后我们从广告中回来，他们带出了一位头发灰白、身材高大的女性。她也有一段录影。她是波士顿人，所以带着很浓重的波士顿口音。她说：“马克是一个害羞而美丽的孩子。”
But on Christmas Eve, 1997, my life as a wife and mother of three was tragically turned upside down when--
但在1997年的平安夜，我作为妻子和三个孩子的母亲的生活悲剧性地被颠覆了，当——
It's all about her son and how he went next door, and there was a gun, and he accidentally shot himself.
全都是关于她儿子的事，以及他是如何去了隔壁，那里有一把枪，他不小心开枪射中了自己。
So instead of celebrating the holiday, we were faced with picking out a casket and planning our--
所以我们没有庆祝节日，而是面临着挑选棺材和计划我们的——
It was very sad. And they showed all these pictures. And, again, the girls were crying behind me. And I was crying at this point, because it was just very sad. And she's crying on stage. And Iyanla was sitting, and she's still making all these platitudes.
这非常悲伤。他们展示了所有这些照片。而且，女孩们在我身后哭泣。我也在那一刻哭了，因为这确实非常悲伤。她在台上哭着。伊安拉坐着，仍然在说着那些陈词滥调。
And the woman, the big African American woman next to me starts shaking and she's like, "oh, Lord, I'm so nervous. I'm next, I'm next." And I'm about to ask her, "what did you do?" And they start with a video of how her son was killed, I guess eight years before, and was shot in front of her. And she "couldn't get over the death of her son. And she started drinking, and she started smoking, and she gained 150 pounds."
坐在我旁边的那个身材高大的非裔美国妇女开始颤抖，她说：“哦，天哪，我好紧张。下一个是我，下一个是我。”我正要问她：“你做了什么？”他们开始播放她儿子八年前被杀的视频，据说是当着她的面被枪杀的。她“无法走出丧子之痛。她开始喝酒，开始抽烟，体重增加了150磅。”
And then she interviews her, and she's crying, and, again, everybody's crying. And it's very sad, she can't get over her son. And Iyanla starts saying, you know, "why can't you get over Earl? You've got to get over, girl. You know you do, you know you do." And she's like, "I can't. I see his face. I see his face in my dreams, and he used to call me shorty."
然后她采访她，她在哭，大家都又在哭。这非常悲伤，她无法走出儿子死亡的阴影。伊安拉开始说，你知道，“你为什么不能走出厄尔（Earl）的阴影？你得走出来，女孩。你知道你必须这样做，你知道你必须这样做。”她说：“我做不到。我看见他的脸。我在梦里看见他的脸，他以前叫我小个子。”
I didn't get a chance to say goodbye.
我没机会说再见。
Say it now. Tell him. You've got to say goodbye.
现在说出来。告诉他。你必须说再见。
I just don't want to.
我只是不想。
Well, you have to my darling.
好吧，你必须说，亲爱的。
You know, they're having this very intense interaction, and everyone's crying. And then they cut to commercial, and she says, "when we come back, we have a 9/11 widow who's going to help Yvonne come back from hell." And that's when I really started to panic.
你知道，她们之间进行了非常激烈的互动，每个人都在哭。然后他们切入广告，她说：“回来后，我们将请一位9/11遗孀来帮助伊冯走出地狱。”就在那时，我真的开始恐慌了。
And you'll hear about her brave battle through the grief, and we'll talk about her road to recovery when we come back.
你们将听到她与悲伤的勇敢斗争，回来后我们将谈谈她的康复之路。
And the bring me up into the chair across from Yvonne, who's crying.
他们把我带到伊冯对面的椅子上，她正在哭泣。
Oh, my.
哦，天哪。
You know, she's a mess. She just can't stop sobbing. The makeup people are running out and trying to reapply her foundation.
你知道，她完全崩溃了。她止不住地抽泣。化妆师跑出来试图重新给她涂粉底。
Oh, my.
哦，天哪。
Yeah. And I start trying to wave to the director, who is this kind of guy with a Caesar haircut. And him and Iyanla are going over cards, and I'm trying to get their attention, like, "excuse me, excuse me, I'm"-- you know.
是的。我开始试图向导演挥手，那是个留着凯撒发型的家伙。他和伊安拉正在看卡片，我试图引起他们的注意，比如，“对不起，对不起，我是”——你知道的。
And at that point, are you trying to plan out something to say to her?
在那一刻，你是否在计划对她说些什么？
Yeah, I felt like, you know, what can I possibly say to this woman who lost her son? And especially since I have a son.
是的，我觉得，你知道，我能对这个失去儿子的女人说些什么呢？尤其是因为我也有一个儿子。
And next thing you know, we start, they go to silence and they countdown again. And she starts to introduce me as a 9/11 widow who started an organization, and her first question was, "Marian, what advice can you give to Yvonne?"
接下来你知道的，我们开始了，他们又安静下来，重新倒计时。她开始介绍我是9/11遗孀，创立了一个组织，她的第一个问题是，“玛丽安，你能给伊冯什么建议？”
And I completely froze. I was looking at her face, she looked so sad and heartbroken, and I was so sad and heartbroken that I just felt completely incapable of speaking. I felt completely inept, and so I really fumbled. And I said well, um--
我完全僵住了。我看着她的脸，她看起来那么悲伤和心碎，我也那么悲伤和心碎，以至于我感到完全无法开口。我觉得自己完全无能，所以我真的很笨拙。我说，嗯，呃——
I would just say reach out. Reach out to people who've gone through what you've gone through. I know it's hard to, you know, you think it's always going to be sad, but we tell funny stories of staying up at night and obsessing. And there's a lot of different ways to be with other-- and comiserating is just so healing.
我会说去寻求帮助。去接触那些经历过你所经历的人。我知道这很难，你知道，你觉得一切总会那么悲伤，但我们分享那些熬夜和痴迷时的有趣故事。有很多不同的方式在一起——共情本身就是一种治愈。
Well, let's call it group healing, not comiseratin'.
好吧，我们称之为团体治愈，而不是共情。
You know, I could tell Iyanla was not happy with my response because she was flipping through her cards. And she actually stopped for a second when we went off air, and said, "I just don't know if I'm really clear on what I'm supposed to be doing here." And she's like, "well, I just want you to give her some advice." And I was like, "OK."
你知道，我看得出伊安拉对我的回答不满意，因为她在翻看她的卡片。在节目录制间隙，她停顿了一下，说：“我真的不知道我在这里应该做什么。”她说：“好吧，我只是想让你给她一些建议。”我说：“好的。”
And they go back on and I said, "you know, I just think maybe being active or joining an organization or"-- you know, so it was really clearly uncomfortable. And after a while, Iyanla just gave up on me and turned back to Yvonne and just said, "Yvonne, I'm going to give you an exercise," and made her start speaking to her as if she were Earl.
他们又开始录制了，我说：“你知道，我只是觉得也许变得活跃起来或者加入一个组织或者”——你知道的，这显然非常不舒服。过了一会儿，伊安拉放弃了我，转头对伊冯说：“伊冯，我要给你一个练习”，并让她开始假装她是厄尔在对她说话。
Tell me what he would say to you. Right now.
告诉我他会怎么对你说。现在。
I think he would say--
我想他会说——
No. Tsst. You say it, because you know what he would say.
不。嘘。你说，因为你知道他会说什么。
"Shorty,"--
“小个子，”——
I think, I know, I know that he would say that he's in a better place.
我想，我知道，我知道他会说他在一个更好的地方。
So, "Mama, shorty, I'm in a better place." What else?
所以，“妈妈，小个子，我在一个更好的地方。”还有呢？
Take care of his baby girl.
照顾他的宝贝女儿。
"Mama, take care of my baby girl. But most important, Mama, I want you to take care of yourself. You know I don't like to see you like this. If you know I'm in a better place, and if you know I'm watching, do it for me."
“妈妈，照顾好我的宝贝女儿。但最重要的是，妈妈，我要你照顾好你自己。你知道我不喜欢看到你这样。如果你知道我在一个更好的地方，如果你知道我在看着，为我做吧。”
I think the whole time I was in there, this show, To Hell and Back, just kept echoing in my head, going, I'm in hell right now. Right here, right now, watching this play itself out.
我觉得我待在那儿的整个过程，这个叫《重返地狱》的节目，一直在我的脑海里回响，我想，我现在就在地狱里。就在这里，就在此时，看着这一切上演。
What's so crazy about that is you're saying you weren't sure what to say, but who would know what to say? It's a situation were, what can possibly be said to somebody, you know?
疯狂的是你说你不确定该说什么，但谁又会知道该说什么呢？这是一个你问，一个人还能对另一个人说什么样的情况，你知道的？
Yeah. I really felt for this woman. She was so heartbroken. And yeah, it's hard. It's hard for people on both sides. I've been on both ends of it.
是的。我真的很同情这个女人。她太心碎了。是的，这很难。对双方来说都很难。我曾处于这种局面的两端。
At my husband's wake there were 3,000 people who came up to me. And there is nothing to say, and people feel so uncomfortable because, "I'm sorry" is all we have really. And that is all we have to say about death. So I don't think there's anything better to say.
我丈夫的守灵仪式上有3000人过来找我。没什么可说的，人们感到非常不舒服，因为“我很抱歉”是我们唯一真正能说的。关于死亡，我们只能说这些。所以我不认为有什么更好的说法。
You know, one of the things about this whole experience you had that's so strange is that somehow, like, if you think about the people who they were bringing up, like, there was the guy who was the alcoholic. And then there was the woman who lost her son. And then there's the woman who had had both things happen to her. And then they bring you on as like, here's the very worst thing we can think of.
你知道，你整个经历中如此奇怪的一点是，不知何故，就像你考虑他们带上来的人一样，有酗酒的家伙。还有那个失去儿子的女人。还有那个经历了这两件事的女人。然后他们把你带上来，就像是，这是我们能想到的最糟糕的事情。
Yeah, I didn't even think of it that way. Yeah.
是的，我甚至没那么想。是的。
You know what I mean? Like you're trumping all of these other tragedies because of 9/11, right?
你知道我的意思吗？就像你因为9/11事件而压过了所有这些其他的悲剧，对吧？
Right.
对。
And then you're going to be the expert who's going to step in and heal and solve the problem of the people who are sort of less expert than you because you've gone through something so much more intense than they could even understand somehow. Do you know what I mean?
然后你将成为那个专家，介入并治愈和解决那些不如你专业的人的问题，因为你经历了一些比他们甚至无法理解的事情要激烈得多的事情。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, I do. And then ironically, I felt the complete opposite because they had the benefit of time passing so that they could heal a little bit. And I felt so fresh in my wound that I really felt like I was completely incapable of giving them insight. But I felt that way a lot about 9/11 in general. People really wanted to learn something from it or connect to in some way or understand it through us, and it was a very strange, and continues to be a very strange experience.
是的，我明白。具有讽刺意味的是，我感受到的恰恰相反，因为他们有时间流逝带来的好处，所以他们可以稍微治愈一点。我感觉我的伤口太新鲜了，以至于我真的觉得我完全没有能力给他们洞察力。但我对9/11事件整体上也经常有这种感觉。人们真的想从中学习点什么，或者以某种方式与它建立联系，或者通过我们来理解它，这是一种非常奇怪的，而且继续是一种非常奇怪的经历。
At that point, you're sort of like a walking symbol. Do you know what I mean?
在那种情况下，你就像一个行走的象征。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Has that worn off over time?
随着时间的推移，这种情况消失了吗？
No, actually. It makes it very hard to date. [LAUGHING] It makes it hard to do a lot of things.
没有，事实上。这让约会变得非常困难。[笑] 这让做很多事情都变得很困难。
Like what happens when you date?
比如约会时会发生什么？
Well, you know, I've had guys say, "I'm never going to fill your husband's boots" and things like that. So I think it's hard to meet people, and who are not intimidated by that.
嗯，你知道，有男人说，“我永远无法胜任你丈夫的角色”之类的话。所以我认为认识那些不被这种事吓倒的人很难。
So at some point in the weeks and months after 9/11, you really became a kind of spokesperson through a series of accidents, almost.
所以，在9/11事件后的几周和几个月里，你几乎通过一系列意外成为了一种发言人。
Yes.
是的。
Were there other times that you found yourself as a spokesperson in just very strange situations?
还有没有其他时候你发现自己以发言人的身份出现在非常奇怪的情况下？
Yes. I mean, I've always been outspoken. I have a very political family. We're all very opinionated people.
有。我的意思是，我一直很直言不讳。我有一个非常政治化的家庭。我们都是非常有主见的人。
Oh, wait, and you're New Yorkers, so you're probably Democrats.
哦，等等，你们是纽约人，所以你们大概是民主党人。
Right.
对。
Did you find yourself in a situation where you were meeting, like, high level administration officials? Did you meet the president? Did you meet--
你有没有发现自己处于那种见到高级政府官员的情况？你见过总统吗？你见过——
Yes.
是的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. I met the president three times. And it was very surreal. I went down for a bill signing, which was a bill he was signing to help the victims families with taxes for that first year. And that is where I met Hillary Clinton, who then invited me down to the State of the Union address, where I met the president again. And then in the second anniversary, which I think was the oddest time for me to meet the president.
是的。我见了总统三次。这非常超现实。我去参加了一个法案签署仪式，那是他为了帮助受害者家庭在第一年减税而签署的法案。就是在那里我遇到了希拉里·克林顿，她随后邀请我参加国情咨文演讲，我在那里又见到了总统。然后在第二个周年纪念日，我觉得那是见总统最奇怪的一次。
My vice president of my organization, who, his name is Lee, and he lost his son, who was a firefighter. And he was a firefighter himself, so he was among all the fathers down at ground zero who were looking for their sons. And his best friend, John Vigiano, had lost two sons-- one was a police officer and one was a firefighter, and they had made a short film about him that won an Academy Award. And for the second anniversary, President Bush was supposed to come up to ground zero and do the whole anniversary thing and he couldn't, so instead they had a small viewing of this movie and a kind of party for John Vigiano. And I don't know why.
我的组织副主席，他叫李，他失去了他的儿子，他儿子是一名消防员。他自己也是一名消防员，所以他当时是在归零地寻找儿子的父亲们中的一员。他的挚友约翰·维吉亚诺失去了两个儿子——一个是警察，一个是消防员，他们拍了一部关于他的短片，获得了奥斯卡奖。在第二个周年纪念日，布什总统本应来归零地做周年纪念活动，但他没能来，所以他们改为举办了一个小型电影放映会，算是为约翰·维吉亚诺举办的派对。我不知道为什么。
And so I told Lee I didn't want to go down because not only was it the day before the second anniversary, but I did not feel comfortable with this administration at all and what they were doing. And so--
所以我告诉李我不想去，因为那不仅是第二个周年纪念日前一天，而且我对这届政府以及他们所做的事情一点也不感到舒服。所以——
This was in the run-up to Iraq by then.
那时候已经是伊拉克战争前夕了。
Right. Oh, yeah. We were already in Iraq.
对，哦，是的。我们已经深陷伊拉克了。
And so I felt very uncomfortable. I said, "oh, you don't want me to go." He always teased me about having a big mouth and saying the wrong thing at the wrong time. And he said, "no, I absolutely want to go with you because Governor Pataki is going to be there." And we just had a rally that day about the memorial and wanting ground zero to be sacred ground and it to be treated as such. Pataki had kind of backpedaled on some things he'd said before, so we had this big rally. And he was going to be at this small dinner party at the White House.
所以我感到非常不舒服。我说，“哦，你不会想让我去的。”他总是取笑我大嘴巴，在错误的时间说错误的话。他说，“不，我绝对希望你和我一起去，因为帕塔基州长也会在那里。”我们那天刚举行了一个集会，关于纪念馆的事情，希望归零地成为神圣的土地，并得到相应的对待。帕塔基在之前说过的一些事情上有所退缩，所以我们举行了这次大型集会。而他将出席白宫的一个小型晚宴。
And so once it was presented that he was going to be there and it was a chance to talk to him about this, then I said, yes, and we went down on the train. And the rally lasted so long we were literally running for the train, trying to make this dinner. Stopped at my friend's house. He told me it was formal, so I put on this sparkling blue gown.
所以一旦提出他会去那里，这也是一个和他谈论这件事的机会，然后我说，好，我们乘火车去了。集会持续了太久，我们简直是在赶火车，试图赶上这个晚宴。在我朋友家停了一下。他告诉我这是一个正式场合，所以我穿上了那件闪亮的蓝色礼服。
And we arrive at the White House and go through this elaborate security system, and I walk out into the Rose Garden, and everyone's wearing business attire, black suits, included the women in brown suits, and I am in this sparkling blue dress that I wore at my sister's wedding. And I just saw all the secret service men kind of, I could just imagine what they whispering into their lapels. Like, "whore in the blue dress has just entered the garden." And I was furious at Lee, who's, you know, he's in his late fifties and short, and I felt like I looked like his hooker, basically. So we went in, and--
我们到达白宫，经过了复杂的安全系统，我走进玫瑰园，每个人都穿着商务装，黑色西装，包括穿棕色西装的女士，而我穿着在姐姐婚礼上穿的那件闪亮的蓝色裙子。我看到所有的特勤人员那种样子，我简直能想象他们在衣领里低语着什么。就像，“蓝色裙子的妓女刚刚进入花园。”我对李很愤怒，他已经五十多岁了，个子又矮，我觉得我看起来基本就是他的妓女。于是我们进去了，然后——
Which is really not a good feeling in the Rose Garden.
在玫瑰园里这真不是一种好的感觉。
No. I was so self-conscious. I'm wearing completely the wrong thing. And I get a glass of wine, and all I really want to do is look at the White House, because I'm like, "wow, I'm in the White House, and so I want to look at the architecture." And literally, if I took two steps out of the garden, there were about nine secret service men following me.
不。我非常局促不安。我穿得完全不对。我拿了一杯酒，我真正想做的只是看看白宫，因为我想，“哇，我在白宫，所以我想看看建筑。”而且从字面上看，如果我走出花园两步，就有大约九名特勤人员跟着我。
And so I was playing with the dog because Lee made me promise not to do anything inappropriate, not to talk to anybody about my liberal politics. And so I was just waiting until Governor Pataki came. And then, you know, I'm looking around this odd conglomeration of people including, Maury Povich, and Condoleezza Rice, and the Rumsfelds. And it was just a very-- and I felt so uncomfortable. I just wanted to go home. I really was feeling kind of emotional about the anniversary and feeling like a hypocrite being there.
所以我只是在和那条狗玩，因为李让我保证不做任何不恰当的事，不和任何人谈论我的自由派政治观点。所以我只是在等帕塔基州长来。然后，你知道，我环顾四周，这群奇怪的人聚在一起，包括莫里·波维奇、康多莉扎·赖斯和拉姆斯菲尔德一家。这只是一个非常——我觉得太不舒服了。我只想回家。我真的对周年纪念感到有些情绪化，觉得作为一个虚伪的人待在那里。
And so we got up to Governor Pataki, and he talked to us about how hurt he was that we had this rally. And I talked to Libby Pataki about some widows that she knew. And you know, we chatted for a while and said what we needed to say, and then I was ready to go home.
所以我们起身走向帕塔基州长，他谈到了他对我们举行集会感到多么受伤。我和利比·帕塔基聊了一些她认识的遗孀。你知道，我们聊了一会儿，说了我们需要说的话，然后我就准备回家了。
But then there was a buffet dinner and a film to see. So we had our buffet dinner, and I sat all the way in the back of the garden at the farthest picnic table in the back. And I'm eating quietly, waiting for Lee to join me, and I hear someone say, "is this seat taken?" And I look up and it's Donald Rumsfeld and his wife, and they want to sit at the table with me. And I was like, "no, nobody's sitting here, go ahead."
但随后有一个自助晚宴和一部电影要看。所以我们吃了自助餐，我坐在花园最远处最角落的野餐桌旁。我静静地吃着，等着李来找我，我听到有人说，“这座位有人吗？”我抬起头，是唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德和他妻子，他们想和我坐一桌。我说：“不，这没人坐，请便。”
So they sat down, and Lee joined me. And, of course, Lee having served in Vietnam and having about 28 medals on his class-A firefighter uniform immediately got into a conversation. And Donald Rumsfeld has just gotten back home from Afghanistan, so they were chatting about all this stuff. And I decided I would be a good friend to Lee and just talk to his wife Joyce about his daughter's rock climbing.
于是他们坐了下来，李加入了我们。当然，李曾在越南服役，在消防员A类制服上戴着大约28枚勋章，立刻就聊开了。唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德刚从阿富汗回家，所以他们聊了很多这类事情。我决定做个好朋友，陪李的妻子乔伊斯聊聊他女儿攀岩的事。
So that's what I was being good, but half an ear was listening to their talk. And I was getting more and more upset, and I could feel my face turning red. And then finally, Rumsfeld turned and said, "Marian, what do you think about all of this?" And I said, "oh, you really don't want to know what I think." And he's like, "no, no, actually, I really do. I'm curious what you think."
所以我表现得很好，但有一只耳朵在听他们的谈话。我变得越来越不安，能感觉到脸在变红。然后最终，拉姆斯菲尔德转过头说：“玛丽安，你对此有什么看法？”我说：“哦，你真的不想知道我的想法。”他说：“不，不，实际上，我真的很想知道。我很好奇你的想法。”
And I look at Lee to get permission if this is OK. And he nods. And I said, "well, actually, I think you used the death of my husband to go into a country we have no business being in." It felt kind of like a cop-out at the time because there was so much more I wanted to say.
我看着李请求许可看这是否可以。他点了点头。我说：“嗯，实际上，我认为你利用我丈夫的死进入了一个我们根本不该去的国家。”当时感觉有点像是在找借口，因为还有很多我想说的话。
Is there some more direct thing that you can say than, "you're taking the death of my husband and using to start an inappropriate war?" What is the mean version of that? What were you holding back?
除了“你在利用我丈夫的死来发动一场不合适的战争”之外，你还能说出更直接的话吗？那句话的刻薄版本是什么？你当时在克制什么？
No, I think I was actually being good. I think if Lee hadn't kicked me under the table, I probably could have said more. And he just kind of-- everything kind of got quiet. Rumsfeld nodded, and he said, "thank you," and turned back to Lee and they continued their conversation. At which point they called us into the screening room to see the film that was made about John Vigiano.
不，我认为我当时其实表现得很好。如果李没有在桌下踢我，我可能还会说更多。一切都安静了下来。拉姆斯菲尔德点了点头，他说：“谢谢”，然后转回李，他们继续谈话。这时他们叫我们去放映室观看关于约翰·维吉亚诺的电影。
And we got up and President Bush and his wife were standing there kind of receiving like a receiving line. And Lee introduced me to the president and said, "this is Marian Fontana. She lost her husband. Tomorrow is also her wedding anniversary." And he said, "oh, that's terrible, you got the double whammy." That's what he said. "the double whammy." And I was like, "yeah, the double whammy. That's right."
我们起身，布什总统和他的妻子站在那里，像接待队伍一样接待宾客。李向总统介绍了，“这是玛丽安·丰塔纳。她失去了丈夫。明天也是她的结婚纪念日。”他说，“哦，太可怕了，你遭到了双重打击。”他是这么说的。“双重打击。”我说，“是啊，双重打击。没错。”
And what did you want to say? What does a person say to that?
你想说什么？一个人该对那种话回答什么？
I just thought it was truly one of the stupidest things I've ever heard. You know, there were some politicians that I felt were very sincere in their compassion for the families, and then there were some that I don't think understood what we were really feeling.
我只是觉得那是真正我听过的最愚蠢的话之一。你知道，有些政客我感觉对家庭有着真诚的同情心，然后还有一些我不认为他们真正理解我们的感受。
President Bush introduced me to Laura and I said, "Hi, Libby." Because I had just been talking to Libby Pataki-- kind of screwed the names up. And Lee elbowed me again, and we slid into the row behind the president in this tiny little screening room. And so then I was kind of up against the wall and Lee was sitting next to me. And Condoleezza Rice and some other guy.
布什总统把我介绍给劳拉，我说：“嗨，利比。”因为我刚才一直在和利比·帕塔基聊天——名字搞混了。李又用手肘碰了我一下，我们滑进了这个小小的放映室里总统后面那一排。所以我几乎被挤在墙边，李坐在我旁边。还有康多莉扎·赖斯和其他家伙。
And then the film began, and I didn't even think about what the film was about. And the screen opens and it's the towers burning, and the shaky cameras filming it. And I lost it like I've never lost it publicly in my life. I just started almost like having an epileptic seizure of grief. I just couldn't-- I was hysterical. I was sobbing really loud, and I had to get out of there. And so I literally just stood up, like a hysterical woman, which I'm not but suddenly became, and started clawing my way out of the row. And I stepped on Condoleezza Rice's foot. And they had pulled a curtain over the door and I couldn't find the knob. And I'm at the door shaking the curtains, and Lee is behind me trying to find the door.
电影开始了，我甚至没想过电影是关于什么的。屏幕打开，是燃烧的塔楼，和拍摄它的晃动的镜头。我失控了，像我这辈子从未在公开场合失控过的那样。我开始几乎像是有了癫痫发作一样的悲伤。我无法——我歇斯底里了。我大声抽泣，我必须离开那里。所以我真的只是站了起来，像个歇斯底里的女人，虽然我不是，但突然变成了这样，开始从那一排挣扎着出去。我不小心踩到了康多莉扎·赖斯的脚。他们在门上拉了一道帘子，我找不到门把手。我站在门口摇晃着窗帘，李在我身后试图找门。
And the secret service men are just, you know, "the whore in the blue dress is on the move." And I ran out to the hall and I was just sobbing. And I couldn't stop crying. They were following me down the hall, these secret service men. I was screaming at them to leave me alone. It was just really terrible. And they got some young intern to show me into a small bathroom that was, like, hidden behind a bookcase and I sat in there for about half an hour just sobbing my eyes out. And that was my last meeting with President Bush. [LAUGHING]
而特勤人员只是，你知道，“那个蓝色裙子的妓女在行动了。”我跑到走廊里，一直在抽泣。我无法停止哭泣。那些特勤人员跟着我走下走廊。我冲他们尖叫让他们别管我。这真的太糟糕了。他们找了一个年轻的实习生把我带进了一个隐藏在书柜后面的小厕所里，我在里面坐了大约半小时，哭得眼睛都肿了。那是我最后一次见到布什总统。[笑]
And do you think it's just the combination of being in the most alien environment possible and then suddenly just like missing your husband so intensely, like it's all coming together once? Like, that's why?
你认为这是因为处在尽可能陌生的环境中，然后突然非常强烈地想念你的丈夫，这一切就像是在同时发生吗？比如，这就是原因？
Absolutely. That's exactly what happened. And it was the anniversary, and I really wanted to be home with my son. And I had that feeling in my stomach like I made the wrong choice. I shouldn't have come down.
绝对是。这就是发生的事情。那是一个周年纪念日，我真的很想和儿子在一起。我的胃里那种感觉就像是我做出了错误的选择。我不该去的。
Did you feel protected by your public role in that sort of situation? That is, you're there as somebody whose husband died, and in a way that it gives you a sort of protection. You know what I mean?
在这种情况下，你是否因为你的公众角色而感到受保护？也就是说，你是作为丈夫去世的人出现在那里，在某种程度上，这给了你一种保护。你知道我的意思吗？
Yes. I mean, I really have never in my life felt more free to speak the way I want to speak. Because I felt like I lost everything, anyway, so there was really nothing to lose.
是的。我的意思是，我这辈子从来没有比现在感觉更自由，可以随心所欲地说话。因为我觉得我已经失去了一切，所以真的没什么可失去的。
Marian Fontana. She's written a book about her experience called A Widow's Walk: A Memoir of 9/11.
玛丽安·丰塔纳。她写了一本关于她经历的书，叫《寡妇的足迹：9/11回忆录》。
Coming up, who'd have thought? Two stories in one program where somebody meets their president. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，谁会想到呢？在一个节目里有两个故事，有人见到了他们的总统。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的一分钟，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program: Not What I Signed Up For.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样关于该主题的故事。今天的节目：《非我所愿》。
We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Small Fish, Smaller Pond. For this act, we wing our way across the Atlantic for this story from Nick Hornby.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕《小鱼，小池塘》。这一幕，我们飞越大西洋，带来尼克·霍恩比的故事。
I was six or seven when I found out how small our country was. I was the last one to know in my class. The teacher pinned a big map of Europe up on the wall and show us the countries around us. France, Switzerland, Italy. And I put up my hand and said, "where are we? Where's Champagne on the map?" And everyone, even the teacher, laughed at me.
我六七岁时发现我们的国家有多小。我是班里最后一个知道的。老师在墙上钉了一张巨大的欧洲地图，向我们展示了我们周围的国家。法国、瑞士、意大利。我举手说：“我们在哪里？香槟在地图的哪里？”每个人，连老师，都笑我。
"You can't see [? Champagne ?] on the map, Stefan," she said.
“你在地图上找不到[香槟]，斯特凡，”她说。
"Why not," I asked.
“为什么不能，”我问。
"Because we're too small."
“因为我们太小了。”
"But we must be there somewhere."
“但我们肯定在某处。”
"Of course, we are, but you can't see us," the teacher said.
“当然，我们在这里，但你看不到我们，”老师说。
"How can you not see a whole country on a map," I asked her. I could feel my ears getting red. The other kids knew something I didn't, I could tell.
“你怎么能在地图上看不到整个国家，”我问她。我能感觉到我的耳朵变红了。其他的孩子知道一些我不知道的事，我看得出来。
"Do you know why we're called [? Champagne," ?] the teacher asked me.
“你知道为什么我们被称为[香槟]吗，”老师问我。
I shrugged. "No, I thought it was because we were champions of something." All the other kids laughed again.
我耸耸肩。“不知道，我以为是因为我们是某种东西的冠军。”其他所有的孩子又笑了起来。
"And what would we be champions of," said the teacher. "No, champe is French for field. We're called Champagne because our whole country is no bigger than a field. [? Champagne ?] used to be a field until we built the village on it."
“那我们会是什么的冠军，”老师说。“不，香槟（Champagne）在法语里是原野的意思。我们之所以叫香槟，是因为我们的整个国家并不比一个原野大。[香槟]过去是一个原野，直到我们在上面盖了村子。”
"You mean we're the only village in the country?" I couldn't believe it. Our village is tiny.
“你是说我们是这个国家唯一的村子？”我无法相信。我们的村子太小了。
"The other side of the stream is France," the teacher said. "Italy is behind the fence at the back of the village shop, and Monsieur Petit's garden is half in [? Champagne ?] and half in Switzerland. You could walk across our country in less than a minute. You could do it while holding your breath if you wanted to. You could even throw a stone across it so long as you threw high and didn't hit Monsiuer Petit's bedroom window.
“小溪的另一边是法国，”老师说。“意大利在村店后面的栅栏后面，小彼得先生的院子一半在[香槟]，一半在瑞士。你可以在不到一分钟的时间里走过我们的国家。如果你想的话，你可以在屏住呼吸的同时做到。你甚至可以把一块石头扔过它，只要你扔得足够高，而且没有撞到小彼得先生卧室的窗户。”
"Why didn't you tell me we lived in the smallest country in the world," I asked my mum when I go home.
“你为什么没告诉我我们住在世界上最小的国家，”我回家问妈妈。
"I thought you knew," she said.
“我以为你知道，”她说。
"How am I supposed to know," I asked her, "if no one tells me."
“如果没人告诉我，我怎么会知道，”我问她。
"What difference does it make, anyway," she said.
“反正有什么区别呢，”她说。
"I know everyone who lives in our whole country," I said.
“我知道住在我们整个国家的每个人，”我说。
"Well, that's nice, isn't it," my mother asked me. I wasn't sure about that.
“嗯，那很好，不是吗，”我母亲问我。我对此不太确定。
"Anyway, don't countries have presidents and prime ministers and things?"
“反正，国家不是应该有总统、总理之类的吗？”
"Of course," said my mother. "We're no different."
“当然，”我母亲说。“我们没有什么不同。”
"OK, so who's the president of [? Champagne?" ?]
“好吧，那么[香槟]的总统是谁？”
"I am," she said. I looked at her face to see if she was joking, but she wasn't.
“我，”她说。我看着她的脸，想看她是不是在开玩笑，但她不是。
"You're the president of [? Champagne? ?] You?"
“你是[香槟]的总统？你？”
"Yes," she said. "I thought you knew that, too."
“是的，”她说。“我以为你也知道这一点。”
"You don't-- you don't do anything. You just make our sandwiches and do the washing."
“你没有——你什么都不做。你只是给我们做三明治和洗衣服。”
"I go to a meeting once a month in Monsieur Gramonde's bar," she said.
“我每个月去格蒙德先生的酒吧开一次会，”她说。
I knew about those meetings. All the grownups in the village talk about litter, and mending the fences so that the cows don't wander into the road.
我知道那些会议。村里的所有大人们都谈论垃圾，修理栅栏，这样牛就不会漫步到马路上。
"Well, what about saluting soldiers," I asked her. You have to remember, I was very young.
“那么，向士兵敬礼呢，”我问她。你得记住，我当时很年轻。
"We don't have any soldiers," she said.
“我们没有任何士兵，”她说。
"And what about putting people in prison?"
“那么把人关进监狱呢？”
"We don't have a prison," she said.
“我们没有监狱，”她说。
And we went on like that for a little while until I understood that [? Champagne ?] isn't really a country in the same way that Italy is a country, or France, or America. It doesn't have its own stamps or money or television or prisons or soldiers or air force or navy. Anyone could invade us tomorrow if they wanted to, but no one wants to. There wouldn't be any point. No big countries need an extra field, a shop, and a cafe.
我们就这样谈了一会儿，直到我明白[香槟]其实不像意大利、法国或美国那样是一个真正意义上的国家。它没有自己的邮票、货币、电视、监狱、士兵、空军或海军。如果有人想，明天任何人都可能入侵我们，但没人想。这没有任何意义。没有大国需要一个额外的原野、商店和咖啡馆。
But even though we didn't have most things you'd kind in normal countries, we did have our own soccer team.
但即使我们没有正常国家里那种东西，我们也有自己的足球队。
My dad broke his leg because of soccer. He wasn't playing, though. What happened was that he was watching a game on TV and the TV suddenly started flickering and then smoke came out of it and the screen went black.
我爸爸因为足球摔断了腿。不过他没在踢球。发生的事情是他正在电视上看比赛，电视突然开始闪烁，然后冒出了烟，屏幕变黑了。
I wasn't watching. I was reading on the sofa. I hate all sports, especially soccer, because soccer is the one that people talk about the most. He was really annoyed that the TV was broken. He stood up and he kicked his chair.
我当时没在看。我在沙发上读书。我讨厌所有的运动，尤其是足球，因为足球是人们谈论得最多的话题。他非常恼火电视坏了。他站起来踢了椅子一脚。
"What about the old one," my mother said. "The little one worked perfectly well." She was angry when my father bought a new TV. She said we didn't need a big screen, but that's because she only watches programs where people talk. She doesn't watch sport. If you need to see a tennis ball or a soccer ball, then a small TV is no good.
“旧的那台呢，”我母亲说。“那台小的完全能用。”我父亲买新电视时她很生气。她说我们不需要大屏幕，但那是因为她只看人们谈话的节目。她不看体育。如果你需要看网球或足球，那么小电视就没用了。
"Where is it," my father said grumpily.
“在哪儿呢，”我父亲粗暴地说。
"It's in the attic," said my mother.
“在阁楼里，”我母亲说。
He was in too much of a hurry because he didn't want to miss any of the game. He got the ladder, climbed into the attic, and then fell when he was trying to carry the TV down again. We all heard the crack. We knew straightaway that he had broken something.
他太急了，因为他不想错过比赛。他拿了梯子，爬进阁楼，然后试图把电视搬下来时摔了下来。我们都听到了断裂声。我们立刻知道他摔断了什么。
Three days later, when he was pushing himself into the kitchen on his crutches at breakfast, he said to me, "you know what this means, don't you?" And I pretended I didn't, but I did. It was the first thing I thought of the moment he fell out.
三天后，当他拄着拐杖在早餐时把自己推向厨房时，他对我说：“你知道这意味着什么，对吧？”我假装不知道，但我知道。他摔倒的瞬间我脑海里想到的第一件事就是这个。
"What does it mean," I asked him.
“意味着什么，”我问他。
"It means you have to play," he said. I didn't say anything. "You have to," he said again.
“意味着你必须踢球，”他说。我什么也没说。“你必须，”他又说。
"I don't," I said. "There's no law that says so."
“我不踢，”我说。“法律没有规定。”
Including my dad, there are exactly 11 men and boys in [? Champagne ?] who can run up and down a soccer pitch, and they all play for the national team. No one has ever refused, even though it's torture. We should be playing against other villages, but because we're a country, then we play against other countries.
包括我爸爸，[香槟]里正好有11个能在足球场上跑来跑去的男人和男孩，他们都是国家队的球员。从来没有人拒绝过，尽管这是一种折磨。我们应该和其他村子比赛，但因为我们是一个国家，所以我们和其他国家比赛。
They're not big countries. We play against San Marino and the Vatican and places like that. But all these places have more than 11 players to choose from, and they all beat us hollow. San Marino, for example, usually lose their games against Italy or France by 9 or 10 goals. But when they play [? Champagne, ?] they beat us 30-0.
他们不是大国。我们和圣马力诺、梵蒂冈之类的地方比赛。但所有这些地方都有超过11名球员可供选择，他们都把我们彻底打败了。例如，圣马力诺通常在对阵意大利或法国时以9或10个球输掉比赛。但当他们对阵[香槟]时，他们以30比0击败我们。
No one had ever asked me to play before because I was too young, and because I wasn't any good at sports anyway. And, I'll admit it, I was a little bit fat. Not gross, just chubby, I suppose you'd call it. I spent a lot of time reading books and playing chess, and not so much time running around like a lunatic, which is how the other kids around here behave.
以前从来没有人请我踢球，因为我太小了，而且我本来也不擅长运动。而且，我承认，我有点胖。算不上恶心，我想只是有点肉嘟嘟的吧。我花了很多时间看书和下棋，而不是像个疯子一样到处乱跑，那正是这里其他孩子表现出来的样子。
But now I was 14, and I knew that if anything happened to any of the other players, I was the next in line. And now something had happened, to my dad, of all people.
但现在我14岁了，我知道如果其他球员发生什么事，我就是下一个候选人。现在发生了一些事，竟然发生在我爸爸身上。
"How many kids of your age can say they've played soccer for their country," my dad asked.
“多少你这个年纪的孩子能说他们为自己的国家踢过足球，”我爸爸问。
"It's not really much to boast about, is it," I said. "You're only asking me because there's no one else. If there was one other boy or man of the right age in the whole of Champagne, you wouldn't be asking me."
“这没什么好吹嘘的，不是吗，”我说。“你问我只是因为没有别人了。如果整个香槟还有一个年纪合适的男孩或男人，你才不会问我。”
"Everyone plays," said Dad. "Nobody has ever said no. It's your duty, Stefan, your duty as a citizen of [? Champagne." ?]
“每个人都踢球，”爸爸说。“从来没有人说过不。这是你的职责，斯特凡，这是你作为[香槟]公民的职责。”
"You always have to have 11 players in a soccer team," I asked him. "I mean, everybody does?" Dad looked up at the ceiling and rolled his eyes. "I can't do it, Dad," I said. "I'll just make an idiot of myself."
“你总得有11名球员组成一个足球队，”我问他。“我的意思是，每个人都这样？”爸爸抬头看着天花板，翻了翻白眼。“我做不到，爸爸，”我说。“我只会让自己变成白痴。”
"But if you don't, none of us will be allowed to play," he said. "There are rules about this sort of thing. Anyway, we'd look bad. We'd be the country that didn't have enough players for a soccer team.
“但如果你不踢，我们就没人能踢了，”他说。“关于这类事情是有规则的。反正，我们会很难看。我们会成为那个没有足够球员组成足球队的国家。”
"We're already the country that didn't have enough players for a soccer team. I'm not a player."
“我们本来就是那个没有足够球员组成足球队的国家。我不是球员。”
"Play as a favor to me," he said. "To make me feel proud of you."
“就当帮我个忙踢球，”他说。“让我为你感到骄傲。”
"But that's just the thing," I said. "If I play, you'll be ashamed of me." And then I went into my bedroom and shut the door and read a book.
“但这正是问题所在，”我说。“如果我踢了，你会为我感到羞耻。”然后我走进卧室关上门读书。
A few days later, I was at home watching TV when there was a knock at the door. Mum and Dad were in the cafe having one of their meetings, but in [? Champagne ?] it's safe to leave your kids at home without a babysitter, and it's safe to answer the door. You'll always know the person standing on the other side. It was Monsieur Gramonde.
几天后，我正在家看电视时，有人敲门。妈妈和爸爸正在咖啡馆开会，但在[香槟]家里没人看管把孩子留在家是安全的，开门也是安全的。你总是知道站在另一边的人是谁。那是格蒙德先生。
"The president wants to see you," he said.
“总统想见你，”他说。
My mom was still the president. No one else wanted the job, so people kept voting for her. There didn't seem to be any rules about how long you could stay president.
我妈妈还是总统。没人想要这份工作，所以人们一直投她的票。对于你能当多久总统似乎没有任何规则。
I laughed. "I'll see the president later," I said.
我笑了。“我一会儿去见总统，”我说。
"It's not funny," he said. "She wants you to come to the cafe. Immediately."
“这不好笑，”他说。“她要你立刻去咖啡馆。”
"She can talk to me when she comes home."
“她回家后再跟我谈吧。”
"She'd be your mother then," Gramonde said. "This is presidential business, not family business."
“到那时她就是你母亲了，”格蒙德说。“这是总统事务，不是家庭事务。”
"And what happens if I refuse?"
“如果我拒绝会发生什么？”
"Then I'll have to take you there by force. The president has given me permission to do so. She was worried that you'd be unhelpful."
“那么我只好强行带你去了。总统给了我许可这样做。她担心你不会配合。”
I didn't want to be dragged down to the cafe by Monsieur Gramonde, so I put my shoes on. All the grownups were in the cafe. My mother was sitting on her own in the middle of the room like the teacher used to do in kindergarten when she read us a story, with everyone else arranged around her.
我不想被格蒙德先生拖到咖啡馆去，所以穿上了鞋。所有大人们都在咖啡馆里。我母亲独自坐在房间中央，就像老师在幼儿园给我们读故事时那样，其他人都在她周围排好。
"Ah," she said. "Stefan, take a seat."
“啊，”她说。“斯特凡，坐下吧。”
Someone got a chair for me and put it inside the circle so that everyone could watch me talking to my mother.
有人给我搬了一把椅子，把它放进圆圈里，这样大家都能看着我跟母亲说话。
"This is so stupid," I said. Somebody tutted, probably because I'd been rude to the president.
“这太蠢了，”我说。有人啧啧称奇，可能是因为我对总统无礼。
"I'll ignore that last remark," she said.
“我不理会刚才那句评论，”她说。
"Is it right that you gave Monsieur Gramonde permission to bring me here by force," I asked.
“你给格蒙德先生许可让他强行带我来这里，对吗，”我问。
"I knew he wouldn't have to," she said. "You're a sensible boy."
“我知道他不必这样做，”她说。“你是个明理的男孩。”
I looked at her. I didn't want to have an argument in front of everyone, but I wouldn't forget it.
我看着她。我不想在大家面前争论，但我不会忘记这一点。
"You know why we've asked you to come here," she said.
“你知道为什么我们要你来这里，”她说。
"I wasn't asked. I was ordered."
“我不是被邀请的。我是被命令的。”
"I'll ignore that, too," she said. "Do you know why you're here?"
“我也不理会那句，”她说。“你知道为什么你在这里吗？”
"I guess because of the soccer," I said.
“我猜是因为足球，”我说。
"You guessed right," said my mother, the president. "Because of the soccer. You've been given the honor of representing your country and you said no, is that correct?"
“你猜对了，”我母亲，总统，说。“因为足球。你得到了代表国家的荣誉，但你拒绝了，对吗？”
"That is correct."
“那是对的。”
"And you're aware that if you don't play, nobody can play?"
“而且你意识到如果你不踢，大家都没法踢吗？”
"I suppose."
“我猜。”
"And you haven't changed your mind?"
“而且你没改变主意？”
"No! I hate soccer, and I'm rubbish at it, as you know," I told her. I noticed my shoelace was undone, so I spent as much time as I could tying it up again.
“不！我讨厌足球，而且我很烂，你知道的，”我告诉她。我注意到我的鞋带松了，所以我花了尽可能多的时间把它重新系上。
"Sometimes," the president said, "we have to do things we don't want to do. In wartime, young men have to go to war but they don't want to."
“有时候，”总统说，“我们必须做我们不想做的事。在战时，年轻人必须去打仗，但他们并不想。”
"This isn't a war," I pointed out. "It's a dumb soccer match, and soccer sucks."
“这不是战争，”我指出。“这只是一个愚蠢的足球比赛，而且足球烂透了。”
"Right," said my mother. "OK, then. Will you wait outside for a few moments, please, Stefan? The council needs to talk in private."
“对，”我母亲说。“好吧，那么。斯特凡，请你在外面等一会儿好吗？委员会需要私下谈谈。”
I stared at her, saw that she was serious, and left the cafe. They closed the door behind me so I couldn't hear anything.
我盯着她，看出她是认真的，然后离开了咖啡馆。他们关上了门，所以我听不到任何谈话。
When I was let back in, I could see that my mother had a very serious expression on her face, and for a moment, I almost believed she was a president.
当我被放进去时，我看到我母亲脸上有一种非常严肃的表情，有一瞬间，我差点相信她就是一位总统了。
"Stefan," she said. "We respect your decision not to play for our national team, but you must understand that living in our small country-- well, as a citizen of [? Champagne, ?] you are entitled to many things, things you probably take for granted. You attend our school. You use this cafe. You buy candy and cookies in the shop. You walk on our roads and paths. Those rights are now withdrawn."
“斯特凡，”她说。“我们尊重你不再为我们的国家队踢球的决定，但你必须明白，住在我们的小国家——嗯，作为[香槟]的公民，你有权享受许多东西，那些你可能认为理所当然的东西。你上我们的学校。你使用这个咖啡馆。你在店里买糖果和饼干。你走在我们的道路和小径上。这些权利现在被撤销了。”
For a moment, I couldn't understand what she was saying.
有一瞬间，我无法理解她在说什么。
"You mean, I can't go to school?"
“你是说，我不能上学了？”
"No."
“不。”
You might think that was no big deal, but it was. The only library was in the school, for example, and if I wasn't allowed to borrow books, I'd go crazy.
你可能认为那没什么大不了的，但其实不然。例如，唯一的图书馆就在学校里，如果我不被允许借书，我会发疯的。
"You're not joking?"
“你不是在开玩笑？”
"No."
“不。”
"You're not going to let me walk on the roads?"
“你不让我走在路上？”
"No."
“不。”
I'd been given a prison sentence. I'd be stuck in my house forever.
我被判了监禁。我将永远被困在房子里。
"I'm sorry if this seems unkind or unfair," my mother said. "But when you live in a small place, you have responsibilities. What you choose to do or choose not to do has much more of an effect than it would in a bigger country. We don't think you should be allowed to take without giving something back."
“如果这看起来不友善或不公平，我很抱歉，”我母亲说。“但当你住在一个小地方时，你就有责任。你选择做或选择不做某事产生的影响比在更大的国家里要大得多。我们认为你不应该在不做出回报的情况下被允许索取。”
My other shoelace had come undone. I tied it up.
我的另一只鞋带也松了。我把它系上。
"OK," I said. "I'm in. I'll play, but only because no one gave me a choice." They didn't hear the last part, though, because they were all clapping.
“好的，”我说。“我加入。我踢球，但这只是因为没人给我选择。”他们没听到最后那部分，因为他们都在鼓掌。
I didn't have to train. I told him that I wasn't going to, and that was the one thing they let me get away with. The rest of the team met every Tuesday evening. They always ran a couple of miles first. They usually jogged up the hill into Switzerland. We can't even go for a run inside our country because it's too small, unless you want to run random round the field.
我不需要训练。我告诉他们我不会去，那是他们唯一让我逃掉的一件事。其余的队员每周二晚上聚会。他们通常先跑几英里。他们通常慢跑到瑞士境内的山上。我们甚至不能在我们国家内部跑步，因为它太小了，除非你想在那个原野里乱跑。
I mean, I know I should have gone to training. I hadn't kicked a ball since I was about three, and anyway, it wasn't like I was super fit. But I didn't want to have to think about soccer until I actually played the stupid game.
我的意思是，我知道我本应该参加训练。我从大约三岁起就没踢过球，而且无论如何，我也不像那种身体超好的人。但我不想考虑足球，直到我真正参加那个愚蠢的游戏。
When you play for a team for the first time, they call it your debut. Well, I made my debut against San Marino, is if you couldn't have guessed. [? Champagne ?] hardly ever played anyone else. The last time we played them we had lost 28-0, but the general feeling was that it might be even worse this time. No one said this was because of me, but I could tell that's what they were all thinking.
当你第一次为一支队伍踢球时，他们称之为你的首次亮相。嗯，我是在对阵圣马力诺时首次亮相的，如果你还没猜到的话。[香槟]几乎没跟别人踢过球。上次我们对阵他们时输了28-0，但普遍的感觉是这次可能会更糟。没有人说是我的原因，但我看得出他们都在想那是我的错。
It was a home game, which meant that we changed in our homes. The San Marino players changed in the toilets of the cafe. My father gave me his red and white striped shirt, and I found a pair of white shorts. I didn't have any boots so I wore sneakers. Then I put on my denim jacket and walked down to the field with dad.
这是主场比赛，这意味着我们在自己的家里更换衣服。圣马力诺的球员在咖啡馆的厕所里更换衣服。我父亲给了我他那件红白条纹的衬衫，我找了一条白色的短裤。我没有靴子，所以穿着运动鞋。然后我穿上牛仔夹克，和爸爸一起步行到球场。
"You might enjoy it," he said. I laughed.
“你可能会喜欢的，”他说。我笑了。
"You don't have to watch," I told him. "It's going to rain. Why don't you go home?"
“你不必看，”我告诉他。“要下雨了。你为什么不回家？”
"Everybody watches," he said. "The whole village, the whole country."
“每个人都看，”他说。“整个村子，整个国家。”
"I've never watched before," I told him.
“我以前从没看过，”我告诉他。
"No," he said. "You were the only one."
“不，”他说。“你是唯一一个。”
That made me feel bad. I felt bad that I didn't know everyone else always watched the team, and I felt guilty that I'd never made the effort. It wouldn't have killed me to do something everyone else did once in a while. When we got to the field, Dad patted me on the back and wished me luck, and I went to stand with my teammates in the middle of the pitch.
那让我感觉很糟糕。我感觉很糟糕，因为我不知道每个人总是看队伍比赛，而且我感到内疚，因为我从来没有努力过。偶尔做点大家都在做的事情也不会杀了我。当我们到达球场时，爸爸拍了拍我的背祝我好运，我就去和我的队友站在球场中间。
I was the youngest player, and Monsieur Gramonde, who was a bit younger than Dad, was the oldest. The only one who really looked like a soccer player was Monsieur Blanc, who worked at a fitness center in Italy. He was tall and slim, and he could do that thing with the ball where you keep kicking it and you don't let it touch the ground. He was our captain.
我是最年轻的球员，而格蒙德先生，他比爸爸年轻一点，是最年长的。唯一看起来真正像足球运动员的是布朗先生，他在意大利的一家健身中心工作。他高大苗条，他能做那种球的把戏，让你一直踢着球不让它落地。他是我们的队长。
"Stefan," he said. "Welcome." He shook my hand. "We thought we'd play you midfield, wide right."
“斯特凡，”他说。“欢迎。”他握了握我的手。“我们想让你踢中场，右翼。”
I didn't understand a word, and I stared at him with my mouth open.
我不明白一个字，张着嘴盯着他看。
"Well, you know your left from your right, don't you?"
“嗯，你知道左和右的区别，不是吗？”
"Yes, of course."
“是的，当然。”
"So you see Michel, there?" He was pointing at Monsieur Flammeny, who's a painter and gardener. "He's the right back. Stand about 20 meters ahead of him and try to help him if he needs help."
“那你看到那边的米歇尔了吗？”他指着弗拉梅尼先生，他是画家和园丁。“他是右后卫。站在他前面大约20米处，如果他需要帮助，就试着帮他。”
I nodded. I didn't think it was a good idea to ask any more questions, though, and in any case, it was time for the game to start.
我点了点头。虽然我觉得再问任何问题都不是好主意，而且无论如何，比赛时间到了。
We let in a goal after about a minute. It wasn't my fault because everything happened over the other side of the field. The tall chap who played in the middle of their defense sort of wandered forward with the ball, and then gave it to another man who was standing right from the edge of the pitch near where my dad and the rest of the country were standing. And this edge man ran very fast with the ball towards our goal, passed it sideways, and someone else, a little guy who didn't seem to do much apart from score goals, kicked the ball into an empty goal. About three minutes after that, the same thing happened. Tall chap to edge man to little goal-scoring going guy-- goal. And then again and again.
大约一分钟后我们丢了一球。这不是我的错，因为所有的事情都发生在球场的另一边。那个踢中后卫的高个子家伙漫不经心地带着球往前走，然后给了另一个人，那个人站在离球场边缘很近的地方，离我爸爸和全国其他人的位置很近。那个边缘的人带球快速跑向我们的球门，横向传球，然后另一个人，一个除了进球似乎没做什么的小家伙，把球踢进了空门。大约三分钟后，同样的事情发生了。高个子给边缘的人，传给进球的小个子——进球。然后又是一次又一次。
San Marino scored 13 times in the first half of the game, and nine of these goals came in the same way. I only touched the ball once in the first half. Monsieur Flammeny got the ball and passed it to me very gently because he knew I wouldn't be able to do anything if he kicked the ball hard. I stopped it with my right foot. Well, I nearly stopped it, anyway. And the next thing I knew, I was lying on the ground and every single part of me was ringing as it I were a bell.
圣马力诺在比赛上半场进了13个球，其中9个球是以同样的方式进的。我上半场只触了一次球。弗拉梅尼先生拿球并非常轻柔地传给我，因为他知道如果他用力踢球我将什么也做不了。我用右脚停住了它。嗯，无论如何，我几乎停住了它。接下来我知道的是，我躺在地上，身体的每一部分都在震动，就像我是一个钟一样。
My head hurt, my back, both my legs, one of my arms. I knew that in a soccer game, people could sometimes be told they weren't allowed to play anymore. It seemed to me that this man, whoever it was-- I hadn't seen him coming or going-- might not be allowed to play football ever again. He would probably have to go to prison for a week or two. I almost felt sorry for him. But when I picked myself up and looked around, no one cared. Everyone was just playing on as if nothing had happened.
我的头痛，背痛，双腿痛，一只胳膊痛。我知道在足球比赛中，人们有时会被告知不允许再踢球。在我看来，这个人，无论他是谁——我没看到他从哪儿来往哪儿去——可能永远不被允许再踢球了。他可能不得不坐牢一两周。我甚至对他有点同情。但当我爬起来环顾四周时，没人关心。每个人都在继续踢球，好像什么都没发生过一样。
When there was a break in the play, I said to Monsieur Flammeny, "did you see that?"
比赛间歇时，我对弗拉梅尼先生说：“你看到了吗？”
"What?"
“什么？”
"What happened when you gave me the ball."
“你给我传球时发生的事。”
"Yes. You lost it. You gave it away."
“是的。你丢了球。你把它送人了。”
"I didn't give it away. Someone came in and smashed me to the ground and took it from me."
“我没送人。有人过来把我撞倒在地，把它从我手里拿走了。”
"It's called a tackle, Stefan. Get used to it."
“那叫抢断，斯特凡。习惯就好了。”
"So that's what it's like being grownup," I thought. "People can just knock you down whenever they feel like it and no one says anything" It made me wish that I was getting younger every yearn, not older.
“原来长大就是这样，”我想。“人们可以在他们想的时候就把你撞倒，而没人会说什么。”这让我想如果我每年都在变年轻，而不是变老该多好。
At halftime we stood on the pitch because there was nowhere to go. Monsieur Blanc gathered us round him.
中场休息时我们站在球场上，因为没地方去。布朗先生把我们召集在他周围。
"Well," he said, "it's obvious what's going wrong-- we have to stop that little guy from scoring all the goals somehow. We're not marking him properly. He's got too much room."
“好吧，”他说，“很明显出了什么问题——我们必须想办法阻止那个小家伙进所有的球。我们没能很好地标记他。他的空间太大了。”
I didn't say anything. I just listened.
我什么也没说。我只是听着。
"I know what we should do," he said. "We'll have to stop worrying about the left side and pull Michel into the middle." Michel Gaurde was an accountant who lived in the village with his mother.
“我知道我们该怎么做，”他说。“我们将不得不停止担心左边，把米歇尔拉到中间。”米歇尔·高德是一个会计，和母亲住在村子里。
I suddenly realized that even though I was the worst player in the team, the rest of them didn't understand what was happening in the game. They really couldn't see it. So what was I supposed to do? I was new to the team and useless at the game, so nobody would listen to me. But if I kept quiet, we'd let in even more goals. If I kept quiet, we could lose by 50 or 60 goals, and everyone would say it was my fault.
我突然意识到，即使我是队里最差的球员，其他人也不明白比赛中发生了什么。他们真的看不出来。那我该怎么办？我是队里的新人，而且球技很烂，所以没人会听我的。但如果我保持安静，我们会丢更多的球。如果我保持安静，我们可能会输掉50或60个球，而每个人都会说那是我的错。
There was something else I'd noticed. Monsieur Blanc was our captain and our best player, but he didn't do anything. He was always standing too far away from the action with his hands on his hips. I couldn't understand it. He was 26 and tall and very fit, and he was happy to watch everyone else do all the work.
我还注意到另一件事。布朗先生是我们的队长，也是我们最好的球员，但他什么也没做。他总是双手叉腰站在离动作太远的地方。我无法理解。他26岁，身材高大，非常健壮，却乐于看着别人做所有的工作。
He saw me looking at him. "Something on your mind, Stefan?"
他看到我在看着他。“有什么心事吗，斯特凡？”
"Not really, no," I said.
“没什么，不，”我说。
"Any tactical changes you want to make?" Everyone else laughed at his joke, and that annoyed me.
“有什么战术调整你想做吗？”其他人都因为他的笑话而笑了，那让我很恼火。
"Yes," I said. What did it matter? The worst that could happen was they wouldn't ask me to play again. "It's not the little guy who scores all the goals we should be worrying about," I said. "It's the edge man."
“是的，”我说。那有什么关系呢？最坏的情况是他们不会再让我踢球了。“不是我们应该担心的那个进球的小家伙，”我说。“而是那个边缘的人。”
"The edge man," he asked. "Who's the edge man?"
“边缘的人，”他问。“谁是边缘的人？”
I looked over to where their players were standing chatting and laughing and spotted him. "Him there, the one drinking out of the water bottle now."
我看向他们的球员站在那里聊天、笑的地方，找到了他。“就是那个人，那个现在正喝着水瓶里的水的人。”
"Why is he the edge man?"
“为什么他是边缘的人？”
"Because he plays on the edge of the pitch."
“因为他在球场的边缘踢球。”
"The winger," said Monsieur Blanc as if I was stupid. "What about him?"
“边锋，”布朗先生说，好像我很蠢一样。“他怎么了？”
"He's the one that gives the goal scorer the ball. Without him, the goal scorer couldn't do anything."
“他是那个把球给进球者的人。没有他，进球者什么也做不了。”
Monsieur Gaurde nodded. "He's right. He's been running past me all game, and I can't stop him. I need help."
高德先生点了点头。“他是对的。他整场比赛都在我身边跑，我没法阻止他。我需要帮助。”
Monsieur Blanc looked annoyed. He thought I was going to say something ridiculous, and instead, I'd seen something he hadn't.
布朗先生看起来很恼火。他以为我要说什么荒谬的事，结果，我看到了一些他没看到的东西。
"Anything else, Stefan, seeing as you're the expert?"
“还有别的事吗，斯特凡，既然你是专家？”
"I'm not an expert," I said. "I just noticed some things."
“我不是专家，”我说。“我只是注意到了一些事情。”
"Oh, well, tell us some other things you've noticed."
“哦，好吧，告诉我们一些你注意到的其他事情。”
I shrugged. "OK. I'm not being rude, but what do you do in this team?"
我耸耸肩。“好的。我不是要粗鲁，但你在队里做什么？”
"I'm the striker. That means I'm supposed to score the goals."
“我是前锋。这意味着我应该进球。”
"But we're never going to score a goal," I said. "We never have the ball, and we're never at the right end of the field." This time a couple more people nodded, and I saw Flammeny smile to himself. "But if you wanted a job to do, you could stop the tall man."
“但我们永远不会进球，”我说。“我们从来没有球权，我们也从来没在球场的正确一端。”这一次又有几个人点了点头，我看到弗拉梅尼对着自己微笑。“但如果你想找个活儿做，你可以阻止那个高个子男人。”
"Which tall man?"
“哪个高个子男人？”
"The tall man who plays in defense. He's the one that gives the ball to the edge man every time. So if you, I don't know, got in the way or something, it might make it harder for them." It was weird, I knew I was right, but there was still no reason for Monsieur Blanc to listen to me.
“那个踢后卫的高个子男人。他每次都把球传给边缘的人。所以如果你，我不知道，挡在路上或者什么的，可能会让他们更困难。”这很奇怪，我知道我是对的，但布朗先生仍然没有理由听我的。
Just when I was about to give up and tell them to forget it, my mother, the president, walked onto the pitch to give us some encouragement. "Bad luck, lads," she said. "Your're playing well."
就在我准备放弃，叫他们算了吧的时候，我的总统妈妈走进球场给我们一些鼓励。“运气不好，伙计们，”她说。“你们踢得不错。”
We all looked at her as if she was mad.
我们都看着她，好像她疯了一样。
"Any plans to change things in the second half," she asked.
“下半场有什么计划改变吗，”她问。
"We're going to double up on the right winger," said Monsieur Blanc. "And I'm going to work harder to close down their center back, cut off his supply."
“我们要对右边锋进行双重包夹，”布朗先生说。“而且我要更努力地去压迫他们的中后卫，切断他的补给。”
It took me a little while to work out that these were my ideas because I didn't understand the words he was using. But when I understood, I looked at him to see when he'd tell her that these were my ideas.
我花了一点时间才弄清楚这些是我的主意，因为我不明白他用的词。但当我明白时，我看着他，想看他什么时候告诉她这些是我的主意。
"Very good," said my mother. "Sounds very sensible." And then she walked off again. I tried to catch Blanc's eye, but he wouldn't look at me.
“非常好，”我母亲说。“听起来非常明智。”然后她又走开了。我想引起布朗的注意，但他不看我。
The second half was really exciting because we didn't let in another goal for ages and ages. Every time the tall defender got the ball, Monsieur Blanc went over to him and stood right in front of him, and quite often he had to turn and give the ball back to the goalkeeper. And even though San Marino were winning 13-0, the longer they went without scoring again, the more embarrassed they became. The tall defender and the winger even have an argument.
下半场真的很刺激，因为我们很长很长时间没再丢球。每次那个高个子后卫拿到球，布朗先生就会走过去站在他面前，而且通常他不得不转身把球传回给守门员。即使圣马力诺以13-0领先，他们没有得分的时间越长，他们就越感到尴尬。那个高个子后卫和边锋甚至吵了一架。
And we all started to run faster and jump higher and tackle harder. The crowd got excited, too, when they saw things had gotten so much better. They knew we couldn't win, and they knew that they weren't even going to get a goal, but as we went 15 minutes and then 20 minutes, even nearly 30 minutes of the second half without letting the other team score, you could tell that they were proud of us. They even started chanting and clapping.
我们所有人都开始跑得更快、跳得更高、抢断更凶。人群也变得兴奋起来，当他们看到情况好转时。他们知道我们不可能赢，他们知道他们甚至不会进一个球，但当我们进入15分钟，然后20分钟，甚至接近30分钟的下半场而没让对方球队得分时，你可以看得出他们为我们感到骄傲。他们甚至开始呐喊和鼓掌。
We made three stupid mistakes in the last 15 minutes and let in three goals. But when the referee blew the whistle for the end of the game, there were a lot of smiles on our team. Losing a second half three to nothing was [? Champagne's ?] best ever international results.
我们在最后15分钟犯了三个愚蠢的错误，丢了三个球。但当裁判吹响比赛结束的哨声时，我们的球队里有很多笑容。下半场以0比3输球是[香槟]最好的国际比赛结果。
"Just think," said Gramonde. "If we could play like that in the first half and the second half, here we'd lose every game 6-0 [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Flammeny."
“想想看，”格蒙德说。“如果我们能在上半场和下半场都这样踢，我们每场比赛都会输6-0[难以理解]弗拉梅尼。”
I knew what Gramonde meant, though. 6-0 felt like a soccer score. Good teams, teams you've heard of, lose 6-0 sometimes. Nobody ever loses 26-0, though.
我知道格蒙德的意思。6-0感觉像个足球比分。好球队，你听说过的球队，有时会以6-0输球。没人会以26-0输球。
As we walked off the pitch, the whole crowd, the whole of my country, cheered us. And then my teammates did something I will never forget. They walked quickly to the side of the pitch, stood in two lines, and clapped as I walked between them. Even Monsieur Blanc joined in.
当我们走下球场时，整个观众群，我的整个国家，都在为我们欢呼。然后我的队友做了我永远不会忘记的事情。他们迅速走到球场边，站成两排，当我从他们中间走过时鼓掌。连布朗先生也加入了。
That was the last time I ever had to play. The next game, they used Gramonde's 10 year old son Robert in my position, and he was better than me. I was told to watch and tell them where they were going wrong. I became the coach.
那是最后一次我不得不踢球。下一场比赛，他们用了格蒙德先生10岁的儿子罗伯特在我的位置上，他比我踢得好。我被告知去观察并告诉他们哪儿错了。我成了教练。
"You've got brains," Gramonde said. "We haven't."
“你有大脑，”格蒙德说。“我们没有。”
In my first game as coach, we lost 12-0. At the end of the game, the team did a lap of honor.
在我当教练的第一场比赛中，我们以12-0输了。比赛结束时，球队做了一次荣誉圈。
Nick Hornby. Hi lives in London, and normally calls it football, not soccer.
尼克·霍恩比。他住在伦敦，通常称其为足球，而不是美式足球。
His story appears in a collection of stories for children and young adults that is a fund raiser for the literacy program 826NYC. The book is called Noisy Outlaws, Unfriendly Blobs, and Some Other Things That Aren't As Scary, Maybe, Depending on How You Feel About Lost Lands, Stray Cellphones, Creatures in the Sky, Parents Who Disappear in Peru, a Man Named Lars Farf, and One Other Story We Couldn't Quite Finish so Maybe You Could Help Us Out. That would be the name of the book right there. That's the entire name. Lemony Snicket's in the book, too.
他的故事出现在一本为826NYC扫盲计划筹款的儿童和年轻人故事集中。这本书叫《喧闹的逃犯、不友好的怪物和其他一些事情，没那么可怕，或许，取决于你对失落之地、流浪手机、天空中生物、在秘鲁消失的父母、一个叫拉斯·法夫的男人和另一个我们没写完的故事的感受，所以也许你能帮我们一把》。那将是书的名字。那是完整的名字。雷蒙尼·斯尼科特也在这本书里。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself without Alex Blumberg, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production from Todd Bachmann, the Catholic.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我制作，没有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、[难以理解]、黛安·库克、莎拉·柯尼格和丽莎·波拉克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼（那位天主教徒）参与制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Ladies and gentlemen, this is very last week when you can call in and get on the radio by telling us your true, honest to God, it really happened scary stories for our Halloween show, which is just around the corner. To get on the radio, call our hot-line. 1-866-66-SCARY.
各位女士们先生们，这是最后一个星期，你们可以拨打电话并在电台里讲述你们真实、上帝诚实、真的发生的恐怖故事，为了我们的万圣节节目，就在转角处了。要进入电台，请拨打我们的热线。1-866-66-SCARY。
You know, you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight from Mr. Torey Malatia, who came up to me earlier and asked, [VOICE OF NICK HORNBY] "OK, I'm not being rude, but what do you do in this team?"
WBEZ管理监督来自托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他早些时候找到我并问我，[尼克·霍恩比的声音]“好的，我不是要粗鲁，但你在队里做什么？”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。